[Music]
last night we were we were taping our
show when we got the terrible news that
that Robin Williams had died and reacted
pretty much we were stunned and talked
about it a little bit with Will Arnett
here on the show but it's an impossible
thing to process obviously and here we
are now 24 hours later you know and it
felt appropriate just to take a moment
here and talk about this absolutely
incredible man how he touched all of our
lives yeah
really such a fantastically funny guy
and everybody knows that side of him
what I think a lot of people don't know
and you're starting to hear all these
stories come out now is how crazily
generous yeah it was so generous such a
nice person
yeah and not just in a material way but
in it with his time I mean you know he
spent so much time entertaining the
troops which I didn't really know about
which means because he didn't talk about
it he didn't talk about he didn't talk
he just did it where there's you know
it's it's not he didn't do it for
publicity right he did it because and I
think the Department of Defense even you
know issued a statement and in in
gratitude for all the work that he done
for the truth he was generous in so many
ways he just said such a generous spirit
as well I you know Robin I knew Robin
just in show business and yeah and we
did a few projects benefits and things
together and he'd been a guest on the
show and for my money best talk show
guest ever probably just really
brilliantly funny and that's obvious to
everyone what a brilliant talent he was
but just as a quick example of what he
was like a bunch of years ago five years
ago I went through publicly kind of a
bump in the road and I was feeling a
little low
out of the blue Robin Williams buys me a
bicycle and it sounds like a silly thing
yeah you know like he was the first
person to buy me a bicycle since my
parents taught me a place it go when I
was 35
but I was I was you know kind of low and
Robin loved to ride and and I love to
ride and he bought me a bicycle but this
is so Robin Williams he bought me this
this bicycle and he had it delivered to
my house and it was the most absurd
bicycle you've ever seen it looked like
a Mardi Gras parade it did it was
beautiful and it really topknot yeah but
it was bright orange and bright green
and had shamrocks on it so I called
Robin up to just I mean who does that I
didn't know him well enough to justify
this kind of you didn't get me anything
and so I knew you had a bike yeah so I
called him up and I just said Robin I'm
floored by this bike and all he would
say is like well I know you I know your
ride and I knew you could use it and he
went
does it look ridiculous I said yeah
let's redic isn't good do you really
like stupid riding it I said yeah I'm
gonna look really stupid he's like well
then that's good then
he had just that amazing spirit of fun
the generosity but also the fun at the
same time and so often I would just look
at that silly bike and think what a
wonderful spirit what an amazing spirit
and we know now that he had his battles
he had his his his and and I think it's
very courageous and things particularly
courageous for someone to be that
generous of spirit yeah in the face of
that kind of depression yeah yeah I just
just such a lovely special man we wanted
to do one thing tonight which is you can
talk about Robin or you can just let him
have the floor so we are going we put
together just a couple of a few moments
from from his visits with us over the
years and we thought it might just be
nice to go back and and have a visit
absolutely let's do that right now
I had a parrot once and do not in any
form put them in your bedroom because
you think will be lovely to wake up to
the parrot yeah because they hear
everything yeah
and there you'll have the bird out and
it'll be one day be sitting there and
your what a lovely bird in the vertical
yes
[Applause]
this is the hairiest man I've ever seen
it frightening it is an amazing thing
I've actually met at the zoo and have
monkeys go what are you doing outside
occasionally I've had to do a thing with
it you know first in movies I've had to
wax and I had a lady one actually once
and it was like this woman halfway
through said you mind if I take a break
you feel like you should have like keep
it on your back nobody knows you
couldn't have a stiff drink or maybe
have a really long talk for the
executives at NBC the bastard I can't
take a joke
[Applause]
in the world Robin thank you so for so
many deliriously funny moments and for
so much happiness that you brought so
many people we'll take a break when we
come back Damon Wayans Jr is terrible
Cena
[Applause]